- So, was there a moment that
y'all knew, like, you know,
it was your ride or die person?
- Yeah, we got dinner
pretty early (laughs)
in our friendship.
And Nicole ordered a salad.
I can't-
- Okay.
- It's in my defense,
it's like-
- [Kelly] I love that
you're defending it.
- I haven't even
said the thing yet.
- [Nicole] Okay,
but I know what you're gonna say.
- [Kelly] You're defending
the salad choice.
- Okay. It was a Caesar
salad, but deconstructed,
meaning I had to assemble it.
And if I wanted to assemble something,
I could have stayed home.
(audience applauding)
(Kelly laughs)
It was just-
- Yes.
- [Kelly] You had to assemble it?
- Yeah. And they brought you the romaine
and then the chicken was over here,
then the croutons are over here.
And then I said, can I have bacon?
And then they brought the wrong bacon.
- They brought the wrong bacon.
It was-
- They brought bits.
- [Kelly] How even-
- I didn't want bits.
- But then, I think this was like
third time was not the charm.
So she, they got bits,
and then she wanted a different version,
but they brought like
a slab, and then she-
- It was like a steak of bacon.
(audience laughing)
It was so thick.
And I said, this is not the right one.
And I threw it against the wall.
- Yeah.
- And-
- Oh my God.
- [Sasheer] She threw it
on the wall, and it just like stuck there
for a minute-
- No.
- And like slid down.
And we both sat across
to each other silent.
And I was like, I'm not
gonna say anything right now.
I gonna wait for her to say something.
And then eventually she was like,
"That was too much, right?"
And I was like yes.
(audience laughing)
Yes, it was.
- Yes, you're crazy. (laughs)
(audience applauding)